do you think a lot of this has to do
with the way our culture has changed in
the last couple years like where you
can't bully a kid now I'm not for
bullying of course but that this concept
where we keep making everything that no
one can ever be offended by anything you
know they took after the Confederate
flag after the shooting in Charleston
now they took Dukes of Hazard off
television dudes that those guys were
not they were not somehow southern white
supremacists you know I mean but they
they took that off television again I'm
not gonna defend Cosby who was one of my
comedy heroes growing up but they took
the cosby show off the air like we're
starting to censor ourselves I think in
a way that's gonna lead to everything
you know every time I watch Seinfeld now
every episode I think in 10 years
they're gonna say this was racist and
massage literally every single episode
salon did a piece a couple weeks ago
about troublesome episodes of Seinfeld
what do we do to combat that well
progressives pray at the altar they sell
flagellate at the altar of non offense I
mean that's that's their their motto we
need to find a way to break through this
thought police I might give you an
example when I used to be a very
competitive soccer player if I were to
today look at the trash-talking that
went on the soccer field between players
which is part of the ritual then
everybody would be arrested today
everybody would be sent to a hate speech
time again right because you mean cause
of racist stuff in homophobic seven
everything off under this exactly yeah
guess what I heard camel jockey growing
up playing soccer and I lived to to love
again yeah right I mean it's called life
grow a parent so so how do we what do we
do about that because that I really like
what do we do to get to grow a pair for
the country or for Canada or well I mean
there are many different ways for
example the culture of narcissism is
certainly not helping the kids the
culture of entitlement right everybody
should get an a-plus everybody should
get a medal everybody should get a
trophy so there's there's several
different movements that have for lack
of a better word pacified the West
you're not gonna be happy with you for
that that's okay all right let's talk a
little bit about some of the
some of the machinations I suppose of
things that are going on on college
trigger warnings and some of these other
things so you were certain you sort of
talked about this a little bit earlier
safe spaces yes safe space safe spaces
is a place where I can go so that I'm
protected from things that might make me
go into a fetal position and suck my
thumb so give me one for example well
why would you go to a sick why would
someone in college go to uh maybe
there's going to be a speaker who's
going to talk something about pro-israel
and I might be a student who is very
much against Israel and so that makes me
feel very threatened at University of
Michigan they wanted to simply show was
it was a called sniper what was it the
movie called and that made a lot of the
students feel very unsafe simply because
that movie was going to be shown on
campus yeah it's astonishing do you
remember when Bill Maher was being asked
to give the commencement speech at
Berkeley Berkeley which is the bastion
the home of free speech in America and
some of the kids there didn't want him
to do it he ended up doing it but he had
a guest I forgot her name I was actually
in the audience that episode he had a
guest who said that he shouldn't do it
because he's against free speech I mean
while she's on her she's on his show
using her right to free speech so
there's there really is like a cognitive
disconnect there he's absolutely I wrote
an article where I haven't done post
where I talked about trigger warnings
and I listed all of the different
concepts that necessitate trigger
warnings pretty much everything under
the Sun I mean literally life requires a
trigger warning yeah is this why
everyone's medicated pretty much right I
think you're onto something you know I
do think there is a connection between
you know if you do all this stuff right
and you give every everyone as the
trigger warnings you give them safe
spaces you don't let them hear from
contrarian views and all this stuff then
you throw them out in the world where
none of this stuff is real cuz you get
out to the world and it's pretty shitty
and you know you're gonna have a boss
that might be sexist or a neighbor that
might be homophobic that is why then
everyone medicates right because then
they're not given the tools to deal in
reality life I agree how's that soil
sciences that's a very nice pop
psychology very nice
that was pretty good